نعود الى السلامه الان في ملاطيا ويبدو ان
هناك جديد بخصوص الطفله التي تجري عمليه
انتشالها من تحت الانقاض سلام
تم سحب الطفله ابلغنا الان بان الطفله
الثانيه تم سحبها لا تزال الفرق بجنب
الاليه الثقيله ترون في الصوره
سحبت الطفله والان هناك محاوله لايصالها
الى
سياره الاسعاف سياره الاسعاف جاهزه
والجميع يطلب من المتواجدين هنا افساح
المجال امام
لسهوله وصول الفريق الذي يرافق الطفل الذي
يحمل الطفله الى سياره الاسعاف لنقلها الى
المستشفى
احاول ان ارى ان كانت باتت في الخارج
كان يسيء
نعم نعم اصبحت في الخارج اصبحت في الخارج
الى الجانب الايسر من الاليه الثقيله
اصبحت في الخارج
يحافظها الان رجال الاسعاف فرق الاسعاف
بمشي الى جانب الطفله
لحظات حقيقه لحظات عصيبه
لحظات عصيبه جدا والد احد الطفلين كان هنا
قبل قليل لم يستطع حتى التحدث الينا يعني
كان في حاله صعبه للغايه
الجميع يكبر الجميع يدعو الجميع يدعو عند
وجود اي اشاره الجميع فقط يصمتون
يتضرعون الى الله عز وجل ان يكونوا فعليا
بخير
عندما وصلنا الى هنا وصلنا على ان الطفلين
بخير حاولنا التاكد اكثر من مره عندما
تاكد الجميع ان الطفلان بخير على قيد
الحياه
على تصيحات التكبير بين الناس مرت اربعه
ايام لا استطيع ان اتخيل ان يكون طفلان
عالقان تحت الانقاذ اربعه ايام في هذا
المرض القارس دون اي مقومات بقاء خديجه
نحن هنا منذ ايام
صدقيني حده البرد القارس الذي نشعر به
ونحن يعني نسبيا مؤمنين هذه الطفله خرجت
الطفله الثانيه حيه وخرجت
ترونها في الصوره
الحمد لله الحمد لله هذا خبر جيد
وسط هذه الماساه هذا خبر جيد
هذه اخبار جيده من بين الركام لن اقول شيء
خديجه لن نقول شيء تتحدث بنفسها سلام وهي
لحظات في الواقع مؤثر مؤثره ومشحونه
بالعواطف اشحون بالدعاء
ومشحون بالعاطفه الانسانيه الحمد لله
الطفلان بخير كما اشرت سلام
الطفل اذا كما نرى على الصور انتشلت من
تحت الانقاض والان بصدد وضعها داخل سياره
اسعاف للتوجه الى المستشفى
نعم نعم
باتت داخل سياره الاسعاف والان الى
المستشفى
[موسيقى]
طبعا
الفضول الصحفي احيانا يدفع بنا للاقتراب
ندرك
حرجه الموقف طبعا نعم ولكن لم نكن لنفوت
لحظه
فيها امل مثل هذه اللحظه وسط كثير من
الامل من الالم